welcome to the program we begin in Iran
where the security unit tasked with
enforcing the strict dress code has been
shut down the decision to stop the
morality police from operating comes
after nearly three months of
anti-government protests and violent
crackdowns on demonstrations they were
sparked by the death in police custody
of 22 year old student Masa amini in
September our reporter dorsa Jabari is
standing by for us in Tehran hello dorsa
what more can you tell us about this
decision how significant is it in the
wake of these protests across the
country and worldwide
well it's certainly a major development
but I think we have to be very careful
we have to look at the words that was
used by the Attorney General Muhammad
Jafar montezeri who made the comments in
the holy city of Gom late on Saturday
evening he said that from where this
unit was formed the morality police they
have been closed now he didn't specify
what will happen to this unit as a whole
he didn't say that they've been
completely abolished of course the
country's laws about mandatory hijab are
still very much in place they haven't
been abolished in any way shape or form
the Attorney General who's been in that
position since 2016 also went on to say
that the Judiciary is not involved in
this entire unit of morality police that
is under the police force in the country
which reports to the interior Ministry
the Attorney General also went on to say
that the issue of mandatory hijab is
certainly very important to the
Judiciary and he said that it should be
taken into consideration that judicial
confrontation is the last step he said
that the issue of improper hijab should
be addressed through cultural measures
this morality police is a unit that was
formed in Iran in 2006 to enforce the
country's mandatory hijab rules which
have been in place since just after the
revolution of 1979 in 1980 it was
mandatory for women to be covered in
government offices and buildings and
then in 1983 the country passed the law
that it is now mandatory for everyone
any woman who comes into Iran and is
living here must be covered when they
leave their home in any public spaces
that they are and also explain to us who
the morality police are and what its
offices have been tasked with doing
well like I mentioned this was a rule
that came into practice became part of
the country's laws in 1983 and this unit
was established basically because the
officials believed that there was a lot
of
um women in the country that were not
abiding by the strict measures that they
wanted to see women dressed in public so
this unit was formed and it's um by a
committee in the country that is made up
of the president the intelligence
Ministry and police officials as well as
the Judiciary officials and they came up
with the idea of bringing this task
force under the police department in the
country where they would be out in
public spaces and they would be
enforcing this rule they became
operational in 2006 and they've been
around for many many places in Iran but
mainly in the capital Tehran and of
course I know many women who have had
personal experiences what have happens
is they are approached by these
officials that operate from a van in
various parts of the city and they are
told that they're not dressed
appropriately they are taken to a police
facility where they are either fined or
they are put through an education course
about what they should be wearing when
they're in public and usually they are
allowed out with a warning the first
time that they are detained but since
Massa amini's death while in police
custody in September there's been
a lot of protests that started as a
result of this specific unit operating
there was many people that believe that
they're confrontational and that they
were using Force allegedly against women
when they were detaining them and this
announcement I think is important to
note that it comes at a time when the
issue of mandatory hijab in the country
or the enforcement of this rule has been
at the center of protests that we've
scene taking place but now those
protests have really grown and
transpired into something much larger
whether or not this announcement from
the attorney general is an attempt by
officials to try and calm the situation
in the country is what many are saying
they believe to be the case since we
know that the morality police have not
been completely abolished all right we
appreciate that update as always Dr
Jabari live for us in Tehran let's get
further analysis now with fuwad izadi
who's also in Tehran he's an associate
professor in the faculty of world
studies at the University of Tehran
fuwad thanks so much for being on this
NewsHour as we heard from dorso our
reporter there there is a Nuance in the
language here that the morality police
hasn't necessarily been abolished but
shut down so is this move actually
significant or is this largely symbolic
and just an attempt to appear to be
doing something following months of
these protests
thank you
well I think what is becoming a
consensus in Iran is that the previous
method of enforcing the hijab laws were
not really working properly and even
before the incident we had a couple of
months ago people were talking about
using other methods and your reporters
talked about
educating the the people who were
violating the law uh you know that what
they did was showed them a video of one
one or two hours you know I teach at
University of Tehran we have a students
with us for at least the term and
sometimes I feel I cannot convey the
messages that we need to convey to
students with three and a half months so
teaching people something in one hour is
probably not a good method so these
things are being reviewed by different
authorities in Iran they are trying to
make sure that the community standards
that Iran has with regard to the dress
code is observed even as you know is
more than 98 percent Muslim so Muslim
culture Muslim populations generally
cover more than the Western
communities that there's a defense set
of the Sanders that comes to covering we
remember yeah I think we see here is
it's not necessarily about the
regulations or the laws that's not in
dispute what is in dispute is about how
the morality police has enforced them so
what does this change or this move this
decision say about the power of the
protest movement which has not only
happened where you are in Tehran and
across the country but also
internationally we've seen vision of
women cutting their hair burning their
headscarves
um Talk us through that
you know um what we know even before the
events of the last couple of months we
have a number of Western governments
that are trying to demonize Iran this is
how they operate they demonize the
Afghanistan 20 years ago before
attacking Afghanistan and they use this
woman covering at that time if you
remember the burger and then after they
took over the country a good portion of
the females in Afghanistan continue to
wear that type of dress because this was
part of their culture and then there was
no news about the fact that the woman in
Afghanistan continued that type of dress
code after the Taliban were gone so we
need to make sure that the immunization
of Iran is something and then the
enforcement of laws with regard to
covering is something else mixing these
two issues is not going to help and to
make sure that the weaponization of news
about Iran is not done and then the
country as I said is looking at the
different methods of making sure that
the the female population is safe and
the female population is not harassed in
in any way yes all right thank you very
much for your insights forward izadi who
is an associate professor in Tehran